thank you yes sir you kept counting
money of Fabiano and we were watching it
so fab welcome to the studio and
congratulations on your Victory today
against Wesley such an important game I
guess for the tournament and for you so
where did you manage to trick him well
he mixed up lines in the opening I was a
bit surprised he went for this line but
I knew some details about it I think
yeah there's theory that goes something
like here and then BC and the point is
of Queen F3 Bishop D7 I think this is
like the point
and there were some games I think like
uh Yan played a game something like this
bishop B7 Queen C2 or maybe was Bishop
B7 first Knight D7 I think Rook fd1
against Guk I forget how it went but
this was some game um Yan was black
against Guk and so yeah this move was uh
not very good and then he yeah then when
he played B6 I understood he mixed up
because he can still play like okay
knight5 I thought Bishop C4 is quite
important mhm and I was trying to
understand this this position but I
thought that he doesn't have like yeah I
don't know B4 first or or sorry E4 I
think was my final decision that I was
going to go for yeah and if he takes the
pawn the problem is his Bishop is is bad
on A5 if he trades it he's worse if he
Retreats and he's losing a lot of time
and he's probably also worse but here it
took me a lot of calculation because
first I was looking at here and then
Queen A4 but then I thought Knight D5 or
something probably everything I was
everything but I I had a feeling when I
saw this queen F3 because the first
point which probably he misses before
very important very nice somehow
computer continues here Bishop A6 I I
want castle and then Rook
D1 um or actually maybe not Rook one I
see mistake but anyway I thought like
I'm certainly better here yes I in some
manner it's a question if you will
convert it yeah and then the other sharp
move is Knight D5 but after Bishop C4 I
didn't see how because Knight E5 I give
this check and after Bishop D7 I take
and queen E4 I think m is good and I was
trying to understand the position like
Bishop
B7 I think and then I thought probably
Castle was strong but I wasn't 100% sure
because a lot of things are hanging and
there's always some tactics here so yeah
but he decided to go for this I thought
it's very logical and then yeah he
should have played here here and now
here and then sack the pawn and okay
black will have certainly some chances
to to draw the game perhaps um yeah like
Knight B5 yes or what I wasn't sure
because I can play Knight B5 Queen A2 I
can play Queen I was thinking Queen D3
is very MH promising end game because
here I force him to take with the other
rook and then I get like Knight A4 so I
was calculating something like this take
take and I think finally just like F3 or
no sorry Bishop C3 this was a final
important move you have two Bishops here
and exra pawn should be yeah maybe he
like some tactics he might survive I
thought he should go for this anyway
because here it just feels rotten like I
don't know probably many ways MH um but
you found this also nice sacrifice
Bishop of seven yeah no I think what I
did was very clean but of course
everything should be should be strong
like the point is if castle and Bishop
B5 is probably just winning in exchange
because I takeen Bishop B4 and if E5
then Queen F3 I think simply and again
he's just not developed um I think like
one important thing I detail I saw which
really convinced me was that Queen C5 I
Knight E4 this ends it completely yeah
because yes Knight D6 okay Queen C4
Knight D6 and Knight D4 queen I'm not so
fast need time to realize things I think
that after B5 it's still required some
calculation because of course I can do
various moves like Bishop A2 Bishop E2
all very promising moves but of course
this is very forcing because if he takes
with the pawn and it's simply Checkmate
Knight E4 Knight H5 I don't know which I
would choose but they both looked like
Checkmate yeah and then here it's forced
E5 is forced first my like my thought
was to go for this I mean but then I
realized that it's not so easy because
if he takes and Bishop G4 I thought and
then F3 and he takes and work d8 I think
I don't know maybe it's still winning
but I thought it's like getting a bit
maybe compated but this was very yeah I
didn't see anything here for him I mean
KN King G6 maybe he could try to walk
but not far away and take you take on C6
yes okay like I didn't believe this and
then if see Queen E4 m i mean like best
case for him he only is down a pawn with
a miserable position exactly okay I
thought maybe he can play Rook B6 here
or something uh but okay he gave me the
second pawn and now it's completely
hopel yeah now it's completely winning
five one second game in a row how do you
feel about it finally you played with
white yeah yeah and uh no I I have to
say I got some good fortune last two
games I mean uh you know Wesley almost
never has games like this so yeah
probably he was a bit nervous because
the tournament situation is like it was
his last tough game it was his last
black game with the black pieces and if
he draws this game then he's probably
going to at least share first right ex
so um okay for me I I have two games
left but he only has one left because he
has yeah he has already had buy um I had
Anish here before and he said that
tomorrow we are playing against him and
he said that it's considering his spot
in the candidates it's better for him
maybe even to lose this game what do you
think about it have you thought about it
no I I after the this game I gave it
some thought and I realized maybe he
doesn't like necessarily want to go all
out because um if he loses it's very bad
for him yeah for the rating and if I win
the tournament then maybe it's not also
not bad for him like that that Wesley
doesn't win so I don't know what his
approach will be anyway I'll I'll try to
approach it like a normal game and of
course it's on him to make some maybe
strategic decision of course he's not
going to lose absolutely he said at the
end that if I lose it's just because I'm
stupid or something but not because I
really wanted to do it but he said just
we we we come into such a weird
situation that this kind of scenarios
are possible yeah of course last night I
was thinking of all because it's very
interesting all the possible scenarios
for the candidates because it's
completely open now like Anish Wesley
even Lenny now has an outside chance but
also gcash um aragi I think has a chance
everybody poweram has a chance I mean
it's like completely wide open race so
it's very interesting because there's so
many events at the end of the year like
in December we we
have and other do you feel you know
comfortable I mean watching all this and
not fighting for the spot anymore yeah I
don't have to to stress out or worry
about these things maybe for for example
Wesley or um or Anish it's actually not
a good thing because it gives them them
some extra pressure like in this
tournament they they don't have to think
just about the tournament but also about
like what happens for exactly yes by the
way congratulations you just crossed
2,800 again
yes you see you're getting closer to
magnos something what we discussed with
you before the turn yeah no of course
overall so far it's been I mean still
two RS but so far it's been a very very
good event for me yeah all the best of
luck for the next rounds Fabby and we're
going back to the studio yeah thank you
Anastasia and congratulations to Fabiana
once more